in the farmlands of Alberta Canada pale
and wretched animals on the area
something is literally draining the life
out of them it is the winter tick as
full and bloated as its host is starving
it's estimated that ticks can drain a
moose calf of half its blood
one dead adult moose was found with over
a hundred thousand engorged ticks
latched onto it
the trouble begins in late summer when
ticks the size of grains of sand
congregate by the thousands at the
optimal height to encounter a moose here
they wait when a moose forges the co2 in
its breath makes the ticks appear to
bloom
as they reach in grasp
the hapless moose doesn't even notice as
they latch on strings of them.the now
grape sized ticks are taking a last
blood meal afterwards the swollen
females will drop off to lay their eggs
and the deadly cycle begins again
infested animals like these are called
ghost moose because their pale skin
shows through
they rub off their coats in a futile
attempt to rid themselves of the
parasites
in search of food and shelter the ghost
moose can become a threat to humans
none of us enjoy having to put down
these animals but once they reach this
type of body condition and show up in
people's yards really leaves us no
choice
I'll get stupid it's gonna go one flat
lane Robert Lamont and Lyle Fullerton of
the Alberta Fish and Game Service have
responded to more moose calls in the
past decade than ever before I think I
think we moved it I'm gonna come through
this bush here towards you
oh never mind I see him moving now at
first they will try to drive the animal
back into the wilderness just walking
toward you go moose go moose but even
shooting blanks
can't send the weak animal packing the
ghost simply slips into some brush this
particular moose is in very very bad
shape body condition wise as well as
being a public safety hazard so we feel
in the best interests of the public here
that we need to put this animal down and
it's not gonna live too much longer so
it's it's a it's a mercy thing as well
it turns out they won't have to put the
animal down after all the not so sure
it's alive well sure enough this moose
passed away right in front of us here I
think I saw some meal look at look at
this just crawling Thanks
yeah well it's probably Anita at it yeah
yeah I spent three months taking that
goat off scratchin ticks for three
months you're you know cold weather - 35
yeah that's a terrible way to die it is
bad
tics have always plagued the Moose but
experts think that global warming could
be exacerbating the situation the tics
usually fall off the moose in early
spring and most died in the snow with
warmer weather creeping ever northward
the parasites fall on clear ground more
survive to reproduce the population
multiplies lethally